Prince William is using his platform to
help make Africa better my visit to Numa
via this week is focused on conservation
there's an issue very close to my heart
and I know it's a matter of deep pride
she warned as well but he's not above
poking fun at his wife Kate Middleton in
the process during his speaking
engagement in Namibia on Tuesday the
Duke of Cambridge explained why Kate was
probably bummed that she couldn't make
the trip with him I'm delighted to be
visiting Libya the first time I'm only
sorry that my wife Catherine is not able
to join me
she is immensely jealous particularly as
I'm looking forward to a few good unsure
uninterrupted night's sleep this week
away from my wonderful children with
kids ages 5 and under we see why Kate
stayed behind to attend to their kids
Prince George Princess Charlotte and
Prince Louie
since the Duchess of Cambridge gave
birth to their youngest child Louie back
in April she's been more selective about
her public appearances and we don't
blame her this isn't the first time the
36 year old royal took a solo trip back
in June he took a five-day tour of the
Middle East and stopped in Jordan where
his wife lived when she was just four
years old while there William recreated
one of Kate's childhood family photos
here's the Duke of Cambridge posing in
front of nearly the same spot the
Duchess stood with her father who was
stationed in Jordan while working for
British Airways
[Applause]
[Music]